Jerald Simon is executive Washington
editor at The Wall Street Journal he
joins us now from Washington Jerry good
morning good morning the president has
previously said that repeal and replace
would would have to happen at the same
time now this this idea has been revived
of the replacement later on what are the
implications well look I think it's a
potential way out of the mess that we're
in right now in the sense that everybody
in the Republican caucus in the Senate
can certainly agree to repeal Obamacare
the problem with it is that repeal and
replace implies the second step involves
negotiating with Democrats and that
involves making concessions as Democrats
that probably involves spending more
money on health care than conservatives
one so the repeal part sounds very
attractive I wonder though how many of
those conservatives who are pushing it
now are really going to be that enamored
of the idea when it comes to negotiating
with Democrats on the replace part but
Jerry doesn't the whole doesn't
repealing it right away create a lot of
confusion well that's the danger if you
repeal it right away you create more
uncertainty in the insurance markets now
the people who are pushing this idea are
saying well we'll make it at maybe a two
year phase-in
for the repeal so that gives us plenty
of time to negotiate a replace part and
by the way two years takes you past the
2018 midterm elections so they're saying
we can keep the markets intact by making
the repeal part a long phase in and that
gives everybody plenty of time to
negotiate the replace part it kind of
puts a gun at everybody's head that says
essentially you've got to figure out a
way to replace this because it's coming
to an end at a date certain you know
you're talking about concessions with
Democrats there's also this idea of just
with constituents and governors back in
states where Republican where the
Republican senators are now visiting
with their constituents and governors
how much of an impact will they have on
what we see well you know ask the Obama
administration how that went in the
summer of 2009 when Obamacare was being
debated and in August Town Hall's
you know opposition exploded so these
things don't necessarily improve with
time back home and you're having a lot
of Republican senators who are back home
now trying to calculate whether the
political thing to do here is to vote
for something that that's unpopular or
to be criticized for doing nothing and
that's really a bad choice but that's
essentially where they are now and
that's by the way where this repeal and
replace idea comes from it's a way to
get out of that Jam Jerry you would say
today analysis finds that the president
tweets more about fake news and actual
policy what do you think
this means for the GOP agenda well look
I think that's it's become a distraction
I think people know more about what
President Trump thinks about morning joe
than they know what he thinks about the
health care bill being negotiated in the
senate and i'm not sure why that's
beneficial to the white house you know
there were some good things that
happened over the last couple of weeks
for the administration a Veteran Affairs
reform bill that got passed through the
house some immigration legislation
victory in Iraq where Mosul was was
taken over by the Iraqi government with
American help Isis was pushed out people
heard very little about any of those
things because of the focus on the
issues the president raises on social
media so it seems like a distraction on
many mornings but this seems more than
just a Washington thing you wrote a
couple weeks ago about civil
disobedience the discourse excuse me
around the country we're seeing today
we're covering live over the weekend on
CBS n states from Illinois to New Jersey
to Maine that are shutting down so
what's the message for these state
legislators as well where Republicans
are pitted against Democrats and can't
seem to work together well what you have
is kind of a breakdown in civil
discourse in civil debate and when
people are yelling at each other they're
not very able to come together and
figure out what to do about some of
these problems and so I think the tone
is not just a tone problem it's actually
a substance problem in the sense that
not here in Washington but as you say in
state capitals it's stopping people from
having the argument and then coming
together at the end and figuring out
what the consensus or the compromise
solution is that's certainly going on
with healthcare right now it's going on
with the budget in many states it's
going on in political discourse in
general in the in the US and I think
that is increasingly clear and it's
increasingly bothersome to people but I
think politicians have to step forward
and do something about it not just boom
owned the fact
all right Jerry side thank you for
joining us Gerry sure happy to be with
you